-Welcome to "The Tonight Show"!
You're here. You're watching.
Big show tonight.
Let's get to some news.
First, you guys, this weekend
was Queen Elizabeth's
platinum jubilee.
That's right. Britain marked
the Queen's 70-year reign with
four days of parades, parties,
and celebrations.
Yeah, four days.
Basically, the Queen is like
your annoying friend who insists
on celebrating
their "birthday month."
[ Laughter ]
Yep, the Queen celebrated 70
years of sitting on the throne.
When he heard, your uncle
who does "The New York Times"
Sunday crossword puzzle said,
"Challenge accepted."
[ Laughter ]
It was a star-studded event
with performances from
Elton John, Rod Stewart,
and Ed Sheeran.
Yeah, when Ed first walked out,
the Queen was like,
"Oh, Harry, you're back."
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's Ed Sheeran.
Meanwhile, Prince Andrew did not
attend any festivities
due to a positive COVID test.
Andrew was like, "It's weird.
I keep testing positive right
before every public event.
Can you imagine the odds?"
[ Laughter ]
Yep, the Queen made several
appearances this weekend.
And at one point, she showed up
as her younger self
in the form of a hologram.
This is real. Check this out.
Look at this.
Yeah. It got confusing
when there was a glitch
and Tupac started
waving to the crowd.
[ Laughter ]
But the carriage ride wasn't
Queen Elizabeth's
only surprise appearance.
She also starred in a short film
having tea with Paddington Bear.
It's really cute. It's real.
Take a look.
-Perhaps you would like
a marmalade sandwich.
I always keep one
for emergencies.
-So do I.
I keep mine in here.
-I love that. Come on.
She's the best. It's so fun.
It went much better than
Paddington's meeting
with another world leader.
Watch this.
-Thank you for the sandwich.
[ Laughter ]
But I'd prefer it if
you took the first bite.
-Yeah, yeah, very smart.
Very smart, Paddington.
I wouldn't -- I wouldn't --
[ Applause ]
Yeah, it was a four-day event
honoring the Queen,
but it was 4-year-old
Prince Louis who stole the show.
Here he is at yesterday's
pageant parade.
Look at this.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God!
-After 20 minutes,
Kate was just like,
"Just hand him the royal iPad,
please."
[ Laughter ]
Now when Kate says,
"Yeah, he's a real prince,"
people know she's being
sarcastic.
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
Prince Louis' antics were
going viral all weekend.
Here's one photo here.
[ Laughter ]
Looks like he's gathering
his strength
for an 8:00 a.m. Zoom meeting.
[ Laughter ]
Here's Prince Louis
next to the Queen.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
That was actually
after she started telling him
"Top Gun" spoilers.
He's like, "Don't say Goose,
don't say Goose."
And, of course,
there's this one here.
That's him pretending he's
a passenger on Spirit Airlines.
That's very interesting.
[ Laughter ]
Switching gears, there are
rumors swirling around
the Vatican that Pope Francis
might soon announce
his retirement.
When asked what he's going to do
next, the Pope said,
"Greeter de Walmart."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, at his age, Pope Francis
said that he could either retire
or become quarterback of
the Tampa Bay Buccaneers.
That's interesting.
[ Laughter ]
You guys hear about this?
The new head of CNN said that
the network is going to stop
using the "breaking news"
banner.
They said they use it too much.
He's got a point.
They do use it quite a bit.
If you don't believe me, take
a look at some of the stories
they classified as
breaking news today.
First, there was this.
"Poll says 54% of Americans do
something the other 46% don't."
[ Laughter ]
-Breaking news?
-That's breaking news.
-Yeah.
-There was also this story here.
"You know that celebrity who was
dating that other celebrity?
Well, now she's dating
a different celebrity."
[ Laughter ]
These aren't breaking --
And finally, this one says,
"Glenn holding steady at 547th
most popular baby name."
[ Applause ]
Breaking news.
-Breaking news.
-Breaking news,
Glenn with two N's.
That's right, CNN is trying to
tone things down
with their "breaking news"
graphics.
Meanwhile, MSNBC is going in
the exact opposite direction.
Yep. Check out what I saw
this morning.
Watch their breaking-news alert
on MSNBC.
-Breaking news, bitches!
[ Explosions ]
-You know what I'm saying?
-Wow.
-It's the opposite.
-It gets your attention.
-I was nervous.
It was just that Glenn was the
547th most popular baby name.
-That's breaking news.
Bitches.
[ Laughter ]
-Listen to this, guys.
Apple just announced a new
feature that will allow people
to edit and unsend messages.
[ Audience oohs ]
When they heard, Apple users
were like, "Finally.
What the duck took you so long?"
You know?
[ Laughter ]
Yep, you can now unsend
messages.
Now everyone gets to play
that fun game,
"Did they see it
before I deleted it?"
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Well, hey, get this.
According to a new study,
the actors whose names we
mispronounce the most are
Saoirse Ronan, Joaquin Phoenix,
and Ewan McGregor.
-Come on, those are easy.
I've never mispronounced
any actor's names.
It's my job, you know.
Go ahead, try me.
-You want me to test you on how
to pronounce actor's names?
-Mm-hmm.
-Okay.
Well, we'll start out simple.
Who's this next to you?
-Oh, that's easy.
Samuel LaJackson.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay. Who's this?
-Robot Diner.
Come on, give me some hard ones,
man.
-You want rapid --
-Rapid-fire me.
-You want rapid fire?
-Fire away, man.
-I'm not sure
this is a great idea.
Alright. Here we go.
Let's just start rolling.
Who's this?
-Easy. Cate Blanket.
-No.
[ Laughter ]
-Eighteen Bananas.
-Mnh-mnh.
[ Laughter ]
-French Fries McDonald.
-No.
-Batman Riddler.
[ Laughter ]
Leggo My Eggo.
Penn and Teller.
Oh, that's Been Eatin' Del Taco.
Gilligan's Island.
Itchy Dandruff.
Tennis Elbow.
Shining Taint.
He'll Want To Bone In The Car.
Oh, I love this guy.
Love this guy. Colon Birth.
-Alright, that's very good.
Steve Higgins, everybody.
Very talented.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Glenn.
-Hey, guys, I read about a theme
park in Pennsylvania where
a ride malfunctioned and left
passengers stuck upside-down.
[ Audience ohs ]
They couldn't fix it, so they
just said the theme of the ride
was "Stranger Things."
[ Laughter ]
This went viral. Two women
in England were relaxing on
an oversized chair, and they
realized that they
couldn't get out.
Watch this.
-Jesus Christ!
Jes-- Use your crutch, Sue.
Use your crutch.
Jesus, Sue, give her
your crutch.
Use your crutch.
[ Laughter ]
-In all fairness to Sue,
it really does look like
she's using her crutch
as hard as she can.
[ Laughter ]
Fake friends help you
out of a chair.
Real friends film you, laugh,
and then post the video
on the Internet.
Anyway, they live there now.
[ Laughter ]